Jonah what's the strangest car you've
had to sell is there real any Oddities
or anything there there's not been
anything that's just really stood out
however what comes to mind with that
question though is my uh my granddad had
this uh limo at one point he had
purchased it from U from an auction and
so he had a limo he sold it to somebody
but I just somebody come up and wanted
it you should drive around in a limo but
you're driving it yeah oh that'd be
great a stretch limo yeah you know be
funny if I bought a early 80s stretch
limousine that had been used for like
600 Proms and it has 140,000 miles on it
but I drive it yeah yeah and then every
now and then Sony you stick your head
out the sunroof and go woo I would love
to be the woo girl I've done that I wed
and then I'd be looking for a low bridge
oh come
on come on oh it just Grays the bun of
your hair that's all come
on so uh now looks like you got some
tattoos on your chest is that right
Jonah you got your shirt open I see some
tattoos there how how much how much ink
you
got that's what I like uh it's it's
that's what I say to that's what I say
to the fellas in a restroom hey buddy
how much ink you got let's see it it's
not weird at all welcome to Jamaica show
us your chest Jonah hey Jonah let's see
that
chest this is how I talk to people hey I
might buy a car take off your
shirt that's not the first time
someone's asking me that is that true
I'm thinking I might buy that car but
first let's see those pecs a little
different kind of test drive I'd like to
do yeah I won't need the
car yeah sorry this compliment turned
crazy really fast oh man no it's okay
it's okay I don't I honestly don't even
know how many uh tattoos that I have I
just know that I have uh two uh sleeves
and a chest piece um I would say that
that's might be 50 or so I don't I don't
know what do you mean you don't so
you're not doing it deliberately or what
happened did you fall asleep and someone
tattooed you no it's just at at some
point after you've had so many you just
kind of stop keeping count and like you
know so I don't I don't really know
exactly how many I have at this point
but you are
laidback know you're incredibly laidback
oh I know I I just uh these tattoos I
don't even know I'll just let people do
it that's so cool that's cool yeah very
yeah like I'm asleep and somebody's just
tattooing me yeah um yeah my friend uh
is the one that did most of them um he
was interested in trying to utilize
drawing as like a career but he wasn't
getting anywhere uh that way you know
you can't just sell pictures for a
living usually like drawings so he got
into tattooing and I think I was like
his first one if I wasn't his first one
I know I had to been like in his top
three you let your friend you let your
friend practice on you right that's
correct a great artist I hope
it no it it was actually I think it may
have been the bear here right that's
cool that's really good oh wow that's
awesome that guy's good yeah so he I
mean so I had I had full confidence in
him from from the junk pretty much I
didn't doubt him for a second so you
said you have a three-year-old child is
that right I do her name's Ella and uh
in the days uh you know coming up
towards the uh the interview uh I I was
uh talking to her about you and like
trying to say like hey uh dad's gonna
talk to Conan so throughout the week uh
she had been just kind of running around
the house saying Conan Conan a l
three-year-olds do that yeah they uh I'm
huge with the
three-year-olds right before the brain
is completely formed
they're they love me and then once they
have reason the reason Center expands
I'm through um that's really cool though
I would I bet you'd be a really great
dad because you're so chill you know I
think that's a great that's a great
energy to get off of a parent don't you
think I think so to just calm relaxed
sweet that's great energy yeah I think
so I try to just be very calm with her
um you know and and just you know let if
she does something that she's not
supposed to I always just try to just be
extremely calm with her and just kind of
set her down tell her like hey you're
not supposed to do that yeah um you know
so yeah I just try to be very just chill
right with her for sure and then try and
put her in a 1982 Chevy
chevet get in here with a high interest
deferred loan yeah
exactly
that always that's really good parenting
is is put that kid in a I see you yeah I
see you in a in a
Cordoba um did you have a question for
me is there anything I can help you with
yeah Conan I was gonna ask uh if you had
just like a go-to sales pitch I mean
what what would you um you know how
would you word it how would you how
would you act if you were trying to just
sell somebody just you know anything
really
wow well depends on what it is I would
say this heroin oh well I'm sorry okay
maybe that's the wrong way to
go sorry yeah I just was trying to pick
up a product that didn't need a lot of
selling I I think I agree with you I'm
very bad at convincing people to do
something I'm very uncomfortable in that
role I've always more or less tried to
tell people if this feels like a good
situation for you then you should do it
but I think I'd be in a lot of trouble
if uh my livelihood putting food on my
kids plate relied on me selling somebody
something I've and I'm I find myself as
a a as a consumer when people are saying
Yep this is when I go into a store and
they go yeah this is what we have and I
think it's really nice but if it's you
know it's either right for you or it
isn't I'm more attracted to that product
than if someone's saying you've got to
put this on or you've got to try and
drive this you you you know you can't
leave this store without at least trying
it then I just really want out of there
instantly so I agree with your approach
yeah I think so a lot people seem
to I do I think you're doing a lot right
very much app and I definitely think
everyone should listen to Conor Brian
needs a friend available wherever you
get your podcast there it is I'm not
interested right now I I'm not listen to
me I you cannot leave until you try this
Con O'Brien guy now first of all he
seems shrill and off-putting but uh over
time you're going to find your best
friend 31 Flavors I came in for an ice
cream yeah okay Corner BR needs a friend
available in Two Scoops I used to make
up a lot of stuff what do you mean like
I sold watches I used to lie a lot and
when people would ask me questions
instead of asking what the an like what
was the right thing I just made it up so
like you tell them this can you can cook
a you can cook a chicken with this watch
or just this Watch
Works yes this is a watch that I didn't
take yeah or they'd be like where was it
manufactured I'd be like I don't know
Switzerland and it would be like a CIO
oh my God Sona the answer is always
Prague Prague it was made in prog no I
know I I so you would just lie I I would
and people would believe me of course
they would cuz they like they like
people who know what they're talking
about didn't know what you were talking
about yeah but they didn't know that I
didn't know what I was talking about
people like someone who they think knows
what they're talking about you know
what's interesting Jonah and Sona are
both very chill Jonah you're one of the
more
relaxed centered people I've met and
Sona to your credit you are a very
relaxed person who's who knows herself
and is confident in herself yet you're
very different uh types of that relaxed
um Jonah seems principled yeah and
honest and um you will say anything
you'll just tell people absolute
something Jonah would never do
yeah I wasn't even working on commission
like it didn't matter you weren't even
selling watches no you were just in the
store I'm definitely team Jonah not team
go
go well Jonah it was very nice talking
to you and uh if I get to tup below
which i' love to do I've never been
there and I would like to see the rather
modest home where uh where Elvis Presley
was born right I know we then moved to
Memphis went to Humes High
School uh and so his time in Tupelo
isn't that long but uh but yeah I'd love
to go there I would love to go and see
it so I would look you up and we could
tool around and whatever car you yeah
you deem uh you deem suitable absolutely
maybe I can even try to track down that
limo and see if we can drive in the limo
I may also uh I may also tattoo you as
we drive around since you don't seem to
care what goes on your
body yeah just bring it on I'm here for
the
experience